in the Academy each branch of the
Academy nominates people within that
branch in other words the
cinematographers will nominate the
cinematography award and editors will
nominate the editors and so forth so
really the nominations are a
representation of what other members of
the Academy who do the same thing think
about it so it really is the nominations
are really probably the pure you know
aspect of the the Academy Awards because
they're their fellow members of the
Academy who do the same thing who who
are the ones who make that decision and
with cinematography is not just pretty
pictures but you really want to you know
you want to see something where the
visuals are in sync with the story and
are helping to advance the story and
helping to create the mood and the
atmosphere that the story needs in order
to succeed and and those are the sort of
things that you end up looking for and
then everybody gets to vote on best
picture and then once the nominations
come in then everybody gets to vote on
it so if there are five nominations in
editing and five and cinematographer
then everybody gets about the AE the
actors the editors the the makeup people
everybody in the Academy gets to then
vote and decide which is the best
cinematography out of those five which
is the best editor out of the five which
is the best production designer and I
think everybody takes it very seriously